VOTERS ARE BEING
INUNDATED WITH MESSAGING AND
POLITICAL ADS.
AN I HOPE YOU'RE SITTING DOWN.
THIS MAY COME AS A SHOCK.
SOME OF THE ADS MAY BE
MISLEADING.
IT IS TRUE.
A CNN FACT CHECK FOUND SOME
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN THE SUB
SUBJECT OF ATTACK ADS FOR
DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
THAT IS A PHRASE THAT GAINED
STEAM IN 2020.
WHAT IT MEANS VARIED FROM
PERSON-TO-PERSON.
SO AS WE START TO LOOK AT SOME
OF THE DIFFERENT ADS, LET'S
TACKLE THIS ONE TOPIC IN
PARTICULAR.
DANIEL DALE REVIEWED A NUMBER OF
ADS FOR CNN.COM.
THIS IS FROM CALIFORNIA'S THIRD
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT, KERMIT
JONES WAS TARGED BY THIS AD,
FROM KEVIN KYLIE.
>> AND IF PELOSI HAS HER WAY,
THEY'LL DEFUND THE POLICE AND
RAISE THE GAS TAX EVEN HIGHER.
KERMIT JONES, HE'S NOT WITH US.
HE'S WITH PELOSI.
>> SO WHAT IS THE REAL STORY
THERE ON THE RECORDS.
>> THIS IS A DOUBLE DOSE OF
NONSENSE.
IT IS PURE FICTION CONJURED FROM
THIN AIR.
NOT ONLY DOES THIS CANDIDATE
OPPOSE DEFUNDING THE POLICE BUT
WE KNOW THAT SPEAKER PELOSI HAS
DISMISSED THAT CONCEPT.
SHE'S DONE THAT IN PUBLIC AND IN
INTERVIEWS.
LISTEN TO TWO OF HER COMMENTS
ONE FROM THIS YEAR AND ONE FROM
BACK IN 2020.
>> THAT IS NOT THE POSITION OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
COMMUNITY SAFETY TO PROTECT AND
DEFEND IN EVERY WAY IS OUR OATH
OF OFFICE.
FUNDING A POLICE IS A LOCAL
MATTER AS YOU KNOW.
FROM THE STAND POINT OF OUR
LEGISLATION, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
THAT PLACE.
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS TALKING
ABOUT HOW WE CHANGE POLICIES AND
MAKE OUR POLICING MORE JUST.
>> AND IT IS NOT JUST WORDS
UNDER PELOSI'S SPEAKERSHIP,
DEMOCRATS HAVE PASSED LAWS TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
POLICE NOT TO DEFUND.
SO THIS AD IS COMPETELY MADE-UP.
>> BUT HE GETS A LOT OF
ATTENTION AND YOU HAVE ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OUT OF VIRGINIA.
ALSO A CONGRESSIONAL RACE.
FORMER CIA OFFICER SPAMBERGER IS
THE TARGET HERE, A GROUP CALLED
MOMS FOR SAFE STREETS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> AND ABIGAIL SPANBERGER JOINS
AOC'S EFFORT TO DEFUND THE
POLICE.
SHE SOLD OUT FOR A POLITICAL
CONTRIBUTION FROM AOC.
>> WHAT WHAT THE RECORD THERE.
>> THE RECORD IS THAT
CONGRESSWOMAN SPANBERGER IS ONE
OF THE MOST AGGRESSIVE
INVESTMENT DEMOCRAT HOUSE
OPPONENTS OF DEFUNDING THE
POLICE.
SHE TOLD HER COLLEAGUES THAT IT
IS RIDICULOUS AND ASKED THEM TO
NEVER USE THAT PHRASE AGAIN.
SHE'S A FORMER CIA OFFICER AND A
FORMER LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY,
SO AGAIN THIS IS FICTION.
AND LISTEN TO WHAT SHE SAID
ABOUT A BILL THAT PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO POLICE.
>> THE INVEST TO PROTECT ACT
WOULD HELP GET THE JOB DONE OF
ENSURING THAT POLICE
DEPARTMENTS, PARTICULARLY THOSE
LIKE I REPRESENT IN SMALLER AND
RURAL COMMUNITIES, HAVE THE
ABILITY TO RECRUIT, AND RETAIN
OFFICERS.
THIS LEGISLATION INVESTS IN
OFFICER SAFETY, IT INVESTS IN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESPONSE
TRAINING AND INVESTED IN FUNDING
THE POLICE DEPARTMENTS LIKE
THOSE I REPRESENT.
>> SO, WHAT DOES -- WHAT DOES
THIS AD BASE ITS DEFUND THE
POLICE CLAIM ON?
WELL IT MISREPRESENTS ONE OF HER
VOTES IN SMALL TEXT, THAT TINY
TEXT IT SKCITES IN VOTE OF A
POLICE REFORM BILL.
IT IS PROMOTES CHANGES TO REDUCE
POLICE MISCON DUCK.
IT DOES NOT REDUCE FUNDING.
>> DANIEL DALE, WITH 15 DAYS
UNTIL THE MIDTERMS, YOU HAVE
YOUR WORK CUT OUT IN TERMS OF
YOUR FACT CHECKS AHEAD.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>>> WELL, TODAY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT EARLY VOTING IN GEORGIA.
KICKS OFF TODAY IN FLORIDA AND
THERE IS A MAJOR DEBATE TONIGHT.
JOINING ME NOW TO TALK ABOUT ALL
THINGS MIDTERMS FORMER
REPUBLICAN CONGRESS FRANCIS
ROONEY.
GOOD TO SEE YOU THIS MORNING.
NICE TO HAVE YOU WITH US.
SO WE LOOK AT THIS DEBATE AND A
LOT OF FOCUS IS ON THIS DEBATE
NOT JUST IN THE STATE OF
FLORIDA, BUT PLENTY OF NATIONAL
ATTENTION AS WELL.
AT THIS POINT, IS CHARLIE
CRIST'S TURN AS GOVERNOR FOR THE
STATE OF FLORIDA IN THE PAST, IS
IT A STRENGTH OR A VULNERABILITY
GOING INTO TONIGHT'S DEBATE?
>> WELL I THINK RON DeSANTIS IS
A CLEAR FRONT-RUNNER HERE.
THE QUESTION FOR RON IS HOW MUCH
MONEY DOES HE HAVE TO SPEND TO
DUST OFF CRIST.
>> MEANING WHAT?
TO DUST HIM OFF MEANING IS THERE
ANY ROOM, WHEN YOU SAY THAT AND
WHEN WE LOOK AT HEADING INTO
THIS, IS THERE ANY WIGGLE ROOM
FOR UNDECIDED VOTERS TONIGHT?
YOU THINK THERE ARE STILL VOTES
THAT COULD BE WON OVER TWO WEEKS
OUT?
>> I THINK THAT RON IS A
WELL-KNOWN QUANTITY NOW.
HE DID WHAT HE SAID HE WOULD DO
ABOUT EDUCATION.
AND HE'S DONE A GREAT JOB ON
HURRICANE IAN.
BETTER THAN SOME PREVIOUS
HURRICANE RESPONSE PREPAREDNESS
ACTIVITIES.
AND I THINK THAT HE'S EVEN
BECOMING STRONGER WITH HISPANICS
IN THE STATE OF FLORIDA, THE
WHOLE MOVEMENT OF HISPANICS
TOWARD REPUBLICANS IS A A WHOLE
SEPARATE SUBJECT.
>> SO WHEN WE LOOK AT THEN,
BASED ON HIS STRENGTH INTO THIS
DEBATE WITH TWO WEEKS LEFT TO GO
UNTIL ELECTION DAY, EARLY VOTING
STARTING NOW.
YOU BELIEVE IT IS HIS RACE TO
LOSE?
>> YEAH, I DEFINITELY DO.
REMEMBER, HE CARRIED A LOT OF
BLACK MOTHERS BECAUSE HE
PROMISED TO STRAIGHTEN OUT
EDUCATION.
AND HE'S DONE IT.
SO I THINK HE'LL CARRY THEM
AGAIN.
THERE WERE OTHER 300,000 MORE
REPUBLICAN VOTERS A DAY, MOST OF
WHICH CAME FROM DORAL WHICH IS
VENEZUELANS.
I THINK HE'LL DO BETTER WITH A
LOT OF HISPANICS AS WELL.
>> WHEN WE BROADEN OUT A LITTLE
BIT HERE, SO MUCH IN POLITICS
HAS CHANGED AT THIS POINT IN
2020.
INCLUDING DEBATES.
WE'RE SEEING FEWER OF THEM IN
DIFFERENT STATES.
YOU ARE SEEING CANDIDATES ON
BETH SIDES SAY I'M NOT GOING TO
DEBATE ANY MORE.
HOW IMPORTANT ARE DEBATES IN
2022 FOR VOTERS?
>> I THINK IT WOULD BE A REAL
SHAME FOR CANDIDATES TO SHY AWAY
FROM DEBATING.
THAT IS A GOOD OPPORTUNITY FOR
VOTERS TO SEE HOW THEY DO UNDER
PRESSURE, HOW THEY COULD RESPOND
AND THINK ON YOUR FEET AND OTHER
MATTERS THAT ARE GERMANE TO
WHETHER THEY'LL BE GOOD AT THEIR
JOB OR NOT.
>> DO YOU THINK IT SHOULD BE A
REQUIREMENT FOR CANDIDATES?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF YOU COULD
REQUIRE PARTICULAR CANDIDATE
BEHAVIOR.
BUT THE VOTERS SURE OUGHT TO
PUNIS
PUNISH THAT REFUSE TO DEBATE.
>> AND THE MEDIA SHOULD TOO.
>> WE LOVE A GOOD DEBATE.
I DON'T NEED TO TELL YOU THAT.
WHEN WE LOOK AT NATIONWIDE,
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF ELECTION
DENIERS ON BALLOTS IN YOUR PARTY
AND THERE ARE REAL CHANCES THAT
THEY COULD WIN SOME OF THE RACES
AND IN SOME TATES, THEY COULD
CONTROL ELECTIONSCH DO YOU THINK
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS DOING
ENOUGH TO PUSH BACK ON THOSE
LIES OR IS THIS SIMPLY MORE
ABOUT GAINING SEATS?
>> WELL, I WOULD PREFER THAT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY ABANDON THESE
ELECTION DENIERS AND RECOGNIZE,
AS I'VE WRITTEN, THAT THE
ELECTION WAS LEGITIMATELY WON BY
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND MOVE FORWARD
ON A POSITIVE SERIES OF POLICY
POINTS THAT WOULD IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF EVERY DAY AMERICANS
LIKE DEALING WITH INFLATION, OUT
OF CONTROL SPENDING, REALLY
DEALING WITH CHINA INSTEAD OF
THIS ON AGAIN, OFF AGAIN EFFORT
TO DEAL WITH THEM.
WE HAVE A LOT OF THINGS TO DO IN
THIS COUNTRY AND I THINK
REPUBLICANS HAVE HISTORICALLY
GOOD APPROACHES TO THEM.
BUT RIGHT NOW IT IS ALL CONFUSED
BY THIS CLOUD OF TRUMP.
>> YOU SAY IT IS CONFUSED BY THE
CLOUD OF TRUMP.
AND THERE IS A LOOMING TURF WAR
IN FLORIDA BETWEEN RON DeSANTIS
AND DONALD TRUMP.
DO YOU THINK THAT COULD IMPACT
THE GOVERNOR'S CHANCES AT ALL?
>> I THINK THAT AS THINGS STAND
RIGHT NOW, THINK RON WOULD GIVE
A -- A RE-ELECTED RON WOULD GIVE
DONALD TRUMP A RUN FOR HIS MONEY
IN PLA, AND MAYBE SOME OTHER
PLACES AS WELL.
I'M NOT SURE GLENN YOUNGKIN
COULDN'T GIVE TRUMP A GOOD RUN
FOR HIS MONEY AS WELL.
>> WE'LL BE WATCHING.
NICE TO SEE YOU THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU.